i still haven't seen anything from the
olympics except the opening ceremony i
saw that because yeah we had like a like
a little viewing party at our place yeah
because uh one of our friends really
wanted to see the opening for something
to be fair it's probably like the most
interesting part of the olympics
honestly mean if you're not into sport
right i feel like you don't even need to
be into sport to be into the olympics oh
no like i like the good storylines you
know it's a story
i mean sure but like i think for like
the majority of people who aren't into
sport and don't care about the olympics
the opening and ending ceremony probably
like the two biggest highlights of like
just scenes i i don't really
care about sports in general i don't i
just i don't know why something about
the olympics is fun it's a thing where
there's just sport that's on all day and
it's changing constantly between events
so you don't have a chance to get bored
like when i've been watching like you
know i might be watching the cycling for
too long i'm like all right okay but
then the next the boxing comes on and i
was like oh okay
and then and then you know it keeps
changing and then like okay and i like
what the [ __ ] is going on like what is
actually right or who is winning
i mean yeah for me the olympics says
i've i've never been really too
interested in the olympics it's probably
one of my least favorite sporting events
just because there's a bit too much
going on for me like at least like no
because we talked about the most
favorite sporting events yeah i mean i
mean we talked about storylines in the
olympics what's worse than the olympics
every other sporting event
i don't know what's better than the
olympia better than olympics well i like
most major sporting events when when
they're when the league doesn't count
rugby world cup as well it's it's just
like it's for me it's easier to follow
along the storyline if just there's just
like one
event or one tournament going on right
with the olympics it's just like what
stage are we at what what sport is this
i don't i've never even heard of this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is handball how do i
get invested in handball when i don't
even know the [ __ ] rules against the
war
i totally agree with you and so i i
could have watched it on japanese tv
probably yes is that i don't understand
fully what's being said all the time
yeah and i feel like i realized when
when watching on japanese tv i'm like
wow actually like knowing who the people
are and why i should give a [ __ ] is
actually really important oh yeah yeah i
thought just being able to leave it on
the background that'd be interesting
that's the whole point of commentators
right so and i realized and i so i got
my vpn and i watched it on the british
uh the british uh website did you use
expressvpn i did use accessories hell
yeah
and
yeah i i was watching with the british
commentary and the commentary was really
good and
i didn't realize how much it added to it
cause there's some commentary that happy
like actually dying like laughing like
uh i think the british rowing team
didn't win like any gold medals one of
the commentators just couldn't hold back
he was so pissed off and he was like the
absolute state of british road we
invested 27 million pounds in british
rowing and we didn't get a single gold
medal and it was just like live on tv
like right after they just lost and it's
like he's just going in he's like he's
like
i felt embarrassed i'm like imagine
you're the rowers that made this guy on
bbc go off on one because i don't want a
tyrant
legendary this is like all the other
good sports i don't know anything about
like taekwondo i don't know anything
about but the commentators help explain
everything as you're going and yeah and
it is annoying when you're watching it
for too long because then they start
over again and they start explaining it
again because they assume that people
are only watching for short amounts of
time yeah they because nobody knows what
the hell the rules are yeah yeah it's
great i mean i was watching like diving
as well diving is really fun to watch oh
yeah diving super fun it was really fun
i was like i was like whoa okay i'm
really invested i think that's the only
like sports that i like in the olympics
is like just the obscure ones that you
never get to see otherwise so it's like
with like tennis and rugby it's like you
know that's playing all year rugby [ __ ]
in the olympics have you seen it yeah
it's like five minutes aside or
something and there's only like 10
minutes of rugby most major sports that
have like bigger competitions yeah are
like pretty [ __ ] in the olympics
like they send like the b team yeah yeah
they don't sound like you look at like
the football or the rugby or like the
tennis yeah
as well yeah oh there's baseball there
yeah there's baseball yeah more like
basketball as well right
yeah like like sports that have like a
competition that's just more prestigious
than the olympics for that specific
sport i feel like it just takes a bit of
the wind out the real magic of the
olympics is watching this small sport
that you've never heard yeah because a
lot of these sports don't have any major
leagues to you know push them and give
them a lot of money in the obviously i
did see a bit of like the uh the
skateboarding because i was interested
in that i think japan got a gold medal
in it yeah like like it's all kids as
well yeah it's like 10 year old kids
yeah i'm like [ __ ] dude god imagine
winning a [ __ ] yeah right what was i
doing in 10 years i realized what's the
olympics this year has been awful like
every single athlete right he looks like
30 the interview he's like 21 and he's
just won the gold medal i'm like what
the [ __ ] man this man is built like a
greek god and he's won a medal and he's
got he's got his [ __ ] together yeah
like you you've reached that point where
i you reached that point when you were
everyone in the olympics is younger than
me yeah no no no you've not even the
olympics or when you grow when you when
you're young everyone you watch on tv is
just older than you yeah it's just like
something you get used to like every
every athlete every major like
personality is just older than you yeah
and then you get to a point where you
start seeing people that's younger than
you and achieving these amazing
achieving these amazing things and like
starting football i'm like geez like at
21 i was [ __ ] masturbating and eating
cheetos like meanwhile these kids just
won a [ __ ] olympic gold medal yeah i
was getting really pissed off because
every single time they introduced
someone they were just younger than me
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this where's
the where's the 30 year old get it get
him in what does he do he he's he's the
veteran
yeah [ __ ] bro the coach is like 27 years
old it's like jesus pissing me off i'm
like this is this surely surely there
has to be someone at age 24 that's why i
kind of almost prefer the winter
olympics a lot of times because i feel
that in the winter olympics there's more
of those like more niche sports that you
really only get to see in the olympics
otherwise you really have to go deep for
it like curling for example is like
i never thought i would care about
curling until i watched the curling like
two winter olympics back and i'm like
damn i want to try this this looks fun
as [ __ ] because i didn't even know the
rules to calling at first i was like
it's just a bunch of people scrubbing
some ice like all right cool so but then
when you actually like learn the
intricacies of the game it's just like
all right that's actually like really
cool i don't understand why like every
country just doesn't agree to take like
a week off during the olympics well to
just sit down and watch it sit down
chill watch it why not every every
country can you know have a week off
seems like the world economy might have
a different a small issue with that
i don't know i don't know i mean it's
like once every what four years right
yeah you're going to take a week off
i mean okay
dude do you get do you get patriotic at
all during the olympics
i i listen to what the commentators tell
me to do
the commentators tell me i should care
about something i'm like all right i'm
caring do you get patriotic at all about
like any sporting event
oh yeah uh league of legends i want the
you boys to win well i mean obviously i
was like
anything else uh for me the world cup
and the euros yeah i was i actually
stayed up i watched the euros and
watched england get beaten this time
yeah in the finals once again good um
and uh it was it was horrible i had to
record trash taste like the day as well
which is why i was until like four years
if you remember last time we recorded
trash this was absolutely dead yeah
that's because i was like watching
[ __ ] england just int
well
i do get patriotic over like whales and
rugby i want wales to win rugby oh yeah
and then if whales get knocked out of
something and england is still in it
it's like okay now i'm rooting for
england to lose
you'd think it would be like you'd think
motion would be like
england yeah
it's like no no that's
the problem is with english people is
that they're the worst when they win at
the sport they like yeah every time they
win it's like every single country hates
them because they're just they somehow
are the worst country at winning yeah
they're like bad losers yeah all bad
winners well it's just like every single
country hates having the fans in their
country yeah yeah because they're the
worst yeah it's terrible
like like people think because you're
welsh part of great britain they're well
sean in it you're gonna you've root for
england right and it's the complete
[ __ ] opposite now
except if it's the other way around like
i remember
when uh andy murray won wimbledon it was
like it was like britain's first win in
wimbledon god knows how many years it
was like [ __ ] decades right
um and it was like the only time where
like a british like english people are
happy to cheer for like scottish people
because annie murray scottish i believe
yeah um but they aren't happy to cheer
the other way around everyone hates
english people right
that's true
and normally english people won't cheer
for scottish people welsh people but
once it's great britain everything's
fine everyone's funny buddy everyone's
buddy buddy again it's team gb now which
is really [ __ ] confusing because
depending on the sport is it's totally
up to the sport whether or not it's a
welsh scottish and english team right or
if it's a
uh a british team or some i think
there's one or two sports where wales
and england are combined but scotland
isn't yeah so it's really cool
like system of like whales scotland is
just so confusing to someone outside of
that country like i've had it explained
to me about three or four times i
believe by you two and i still don't
understand what it is not that
complicated i'm like so what's
considered uk what's great britain
what's the commonwealth what's all this
[ __ ] like it's it's just really
confusing to me i mean what do we want
to get have we do we the siege watch cbc
great video yeah there's there's plenty
of things
yeah there's plenty of videos on it
we're not gonna explain it yeah
but you should learn that wales exists
and see but at least like you know in
the case with like wales in england
right like at least you got you know i i
feel a lot of the same sports you guys
are either good at or bad at right so
like say for example like in the rugby
right wales in england pretty good yeah
yeah they're not like top top but
they're you know usually stay up near
the top right so like at least you have
that choice
i don't have that choice with my two
countries because sports that australia
is good at japan sucks at sports that
japan is good at australia sucks at
so like in the soccer right like japan's
pretty good australia's [ __ ] in the
cricket japan didn't don't even play
cricket
the same with the like the rugby is
probably like the only thing because you
know i think last rugby world cup japan
came like eighth i think yeah top eight
or something it was hosted in japan yeah
which is hype as [ __ ] right because
japan is never that good um that was the
only time where i was like all right
japan you did good but
you're gonna have to go back to sleep
after that there's australia good at
rugby yeah australia's really good and
they're in top four yeah i don't watch
sports often mainly because of a it's
just you know especially when we live in
this time zone what the [ __ ] when the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] happening the reason
why it's so easy to keep along with the
olympics is because it's just all day
yeah yeah it's great i wake up it's on i
go to bed it's on like
i mean that's kind of what i liked about
big sporting competitions you know any
any age i was where you turn on the tv
and it's just sports playing and it's
just it's just fun and it's fun to watch
something where every match
matters to somebody i just wish i knew
more about who was competing yeah in the
olympics no way you can though like yeah
there's no way there's so much
information and then you know even like
i was getting confused because even in
like some of the sports like taekwondo
or some of the martial arts it's like
weight divisions and there's so many
weight divisions there's so many
competitors in the weight divisions and
there might be multiple ones from your
country in the one weight division so
it's really hard to be like all right
wait who am i rooting for what the [ __ ]
is going on i just see the flag and i'm
like oh i recognize that one go that one
that's basically what it boils down to
right it's just like i like my country
let's see that country do well yeah it's
like oh i've never i've never heard of
liechtenstein before i i think they're
good at this sport
they compete in the olympics i don't
even know there's a lot dude like okay
watching the opening ceremony and you
know how they have to like go through
all the countries there's like over 100
countries that were competing this year
but
it was funny because
they were going not in alphabetical
order yeah they were going in like
japanese like hiragana order which is oh
completely different i was wondering
what kind of order they were going in
yeah they seemed like the most
weird order yeah they've ever been done
that's why there were like you know some
countries starting with c that came
after countries starting with k because
in japanese alphabet it's like in the
same order so like i remember my sister
in australia was texting me because she
was watching it as well and she was like
oh it's really funny because these
australian commentators have been
explaining for the past 10 minutes why
these countries are coming out in this
order they literally have to explain the
japanese writing system to an australian
[ __ ] audience to be like oh so okay
so hear me out this is how it works and
this is why it's the weird order but
like i heard dude there were so many
countries in there where i was like that
that sounds like a made-up word like
that's not a real country some of them
aren't i i'm from correct aren't even
countries like uh i think like some of
them are like micro nations yeah some of
the more uh territories territories are
other countries like there's the cayman
islands as well as listed as the south
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't think that is i do i saw some
drama happen live while i was watching
boxing there was like a british guy
versus a french guy
and uh i mean that's drama already yeah
that's wrong already which is that's i
mean let's go let's go back to history
napoleon just makes a [ __ ] like
exposed video or whatever
yeah it was literally like that
and they were boxing right and
so obviously when you're boxing
sometimes you like you did they do the
hugging thing yeah and it's like okay
cool so when they were doing the hugging
thing like i think the french guy was
like head butting the british guy oh
[ __ ] and he like made him bleed and the
ref was like hey don't do that again he
did it again
and then he just immediately
disqualified him right right the french
guy yeah yeah and he had a [ __ ] men
down like a mental breakdown and started
like shouting and stuff going up to all
the cameras being like no i won no i won
into the wow and they were like
announcing it and he was like no stop
announcing it stop it now stop the cow
yeah yeah he was like stop this is
[ __ ] there's no way and he was like
throwing a massive fit it was so crazy
how did i not see that i don't know i i
when i when it was happening i was like
oh [ __ ] am i watching drama live yo
i went to i didn't want any good uh
personality just watch world star yeah
you watched a highly televised world it
was great the live league thing started
popping up like midway it was great
i immediately went to twitter as any
good person would when
featuring drama i was like oh this is
great i went to twitter and i watched it
and i was just watching everyone else
talk about the drama i was watching oh
that's weird because i've seen so many
clips of the olympics on there's a lot
more drama in the olympics it happens
yeah i think i've watched
more olympics on twitter than i have on
television